today on the mat well show a new poll
finds the majority of Americans think
that our country is systemically racist
they're wrong of course but what does it
tell us that so many Americans believe
that what are the implications of this
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the continued
bloodbath in Chicago while the mayor is
mainly concerned with tweeting about
Donald Trump and the left's latest
discovery that BMI which is the body max
mass index which tells us whether people
are fat or not turns out that's racist
yeah
and I'll tell you why and our daily
cancellation I will be canceling the
Trump campaign may not be the most ideal
time to be canceled in the Trump
campaign but I have a good reason I'll
explain that as well all of that coming
up but starting here there's a poll from
the Wall Street Journal and NBC that's
getting a lot of attention it finds that
a majority of Americans including white
Americans believe that American society
is racist is fundamentally inherently
racist and this I believe is the the
largest number that we've ever seen in
these polls here's a look at some of the
graphs so 56 percent say American
Society is racist significantly more
women than men but almost half of men 51
percent or you know almost half of men
and 51 percent of whites believe this 78
percent of blacks 82 percent of
Democrats not surprised there 30 percent
of Republicans which is actually quite
high now I'm not not surprised by that
either but that's quite high 45 percent
of Independence and then if you look at
who exactly is supposed to be the target
of this racism the majority very
sizeable majority say that black people
are you know the ones being
discriminated against also Hispanic
fewer would say Asian and then it looks
to be a little less than 15 percent I
don't know 12 or 13 percent say whites
are the ones discriminated against I
want to talk about I want to talk about
this and talk about what it means but
let me read a little bit from the NBC
report on this because it has more
information and I mean it goes without
saying of course that the reporting here
is wildly biased but here's what it says
amid a moment of national reckoning on
racial issues and the mourning of one of
country's most revered civil lights were
civil rights leaders new members from
the NBC news / Wall Street Journal poll
show or numbers I should say show that
American voters have become
significantly more aware of racial
discrimination and more sympathetic to
those protesting to end it even as the
country remains deeply divided over the
prevalence of bigotry that's root causes
okay notice the bias being worn right on
the sleeve here which is where I prefer
for the bias to be war and I think it's
less dangerous when you're just upfront
and obvious with it this is the
organization that conducted the poll and
but but they don't say Americans think
our country is racist Americans believe
our country is racist now they say
Americans are becoming aware that our
country is races in other words America
is definitely racist says NBC but now
those dumb Americans are finally
catching on that's that's the way
they're framing us the poll finds that
voters in America are now more likely to
say that people of color experience
discrimination to describe athletes
kneeling and protest of racial
inequality as appropriate to view the
black lives matter movement as a
positive force and to support the
removal of Confederate monuments in
public spaces the poll found the
majority of Americans 56% say American
society is racist where'd it went over
that that share is almost unchanged
since The Associated Press found 55% of
voters saying American society's racist
in a July 1988 survey so we're supposed
to believe over 30 years what there's
been no progress not only is America
still racist but there's been there's
been no progress in in terms of
defeating racism even after having a
black president for eight years no
progress
there's we're still exactly where we
were before 2008 just 28% of voters said
the black black Americans are
discriminated against while 51 percent
said they are treated fairly but in this
latest poll the share who believe black
Americans experience discrimination has
jumped to 59% and then the
the first time the poll also asked the
same battery of questions about the
treatment of white Americans about 3 and
10 voters overall say that white people
received too many special privileges
while 53 percent say white Americans are
treated fairly and 15 percent say they
experience those being white people
experience discrimination
now you notice another thing to notice
how confused the poll respondents are
nobody has any idea what they're talking
about here or what they think that's not
just they don't of any idea what they're
talking about they don't even know what
they think because what we take from
this is that a large number of people
apparently who think that American
society is racist in favor of white
people also don't think that white
people receive any special privileges
the number of people who think that
white people were received special
privileges is only thirty percent only
thirty percent say whites are specially
privileged while over 50 56 percent was
it say America is racist you see the
disconnect here there's there's 26
percent missing if America is racist
against black people then we should see
that white people receive benefits that
black people don't that would seem to be
a necessary aspect of systemic racism
that in fact would be it should be one
of the ways that you know systemic
racism exists that should be one of the
symptoms one of the indicators yet some
of the people seems like a large number
of people who think that America is
racist against blacks don't think that
this benefits White's in any way so it's
totally confused all you have to do is
reframe the racism questions slightly
and you get a radically different answer
and what that shows you is is people
again it's not just that they don't know
what they're talking about although they
don't they don't even know what they
really think about these issues we also
know that from from what it said before
you look at that ridiculous jump from
2008 twenty-eight percent of voters said
that black Americans are discriminated
against in 2008 12 years later 59%
okay that's the number has doubled in 12
years well what what happened in the
last 12 years I mean if you didn't think
that black Americans were discriminated
against on a systemic level in 2008 why
would you think it now
what what what evidence can you marshal
what another way of putting it what
actual evidence if you are in that
number the you know 20 the 30 percent of
people or so who didn't think that we
were too systemically racist in 2008 but
now you think we are what what evidence
did you stumble upon in the last 12
years that changed your mind well I
already know the answer to that question
I'll tell you what the evidence is some
a a small smattering of high-profile
cases of black people being killed by
the cops that's it I mean that's your
evidence and also you know just the
chaos in the streets and it'sit's the
other I think maybe even more than that
the evidence that probably has swayed
you is just a lot of people screaming in
your face insisting that America's
racist and finally you got beaten down
and said okay fine it is and that was
enough for you if I'm wrong and if
there's some other evidence that you
came across some real evidence of
systemic racism that changed your mind
then tell me what it is I don't think
you could present it because I don't
think it exists let's see
the article says despite the increased
recognition of discrimination faced by
racial minorities there it is again
increased recognition of discrimination
the contrary remains deeply divided on
the root causes of racism 46% of voters
say that racism is built into the
American Society including into the
country's policies and institutions
while 44% say racism is perpetrated only
by individuals who hold racist views
okay a few things to be said here before
I say those though I want to take a step
aside for a minute to tell you about our
sponsors at Bambi you know HR issues can
really kill you when you're running a
small business it's it's great to have
your small business have all the freedom
that comes with that but if you want it
to run smoothly and if you want it to be
as effective and to get everything that
you can out of the experience of running
a business you need a good HR department
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulators I mean
there's so many things that get in the
way that hamper your abilities as
Casilla to succeed an HR manager
salaries aren't cheap either an average
of seventy-five thousand dollars a year
we're talking about well Bambi spelled
BA MBE was created specifically for
small businesses you can get a dedicated
HR manager you can craft HR policy you
can maintain your compliance all for
just $99 a month so you could have
$75,000 a year or $99 a month do the
math on that with Bambi you can change
HR from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated HR
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business this is
not a cookie cutter approach they're
gonna narrow this down and look at what
you actually need and give you what you
need so go to Bambi dot-com slash walls
right now to schedule your free HR audit
that's Bambi calm slash Walsh be a em be
e dot com slash Walsh okay so on the
issue of Americans thinking America's
systemic the reasons first of all
America is not systemic Lee racist
against black people that's a myth I've
already explained why it's a myth I
provided the evidence I'm not going to
go into it again you can go back and
watch the shows where I've talked about
can read the pieces that I've written or
that many other people have written
addressing this this claim there is no
evidence to support the systemic racism
claim and some anecdotes that you have
that's not evidence anecdotes to include
high-profile very rare cases of black
people being killed by the cops
especially when you consider that in
many of those cases like the Rashard
Brooks case for example the guy at the
Wendy's in Atlanta
we go all the way back to one of the you
know one of the first in this in this at
least in the BLM age of Michael Brown
really the one that started at all in
those cases not only is that anecdotal
but actually this shooting was entirely
justified so of you know how many
high-profile cases of unjustified police
shootings have there been in the last
five years a few there's been a few that
doesn't prove anything about systemic
racism it doesn't even come close to it
I'm afraid to tell you especially
because as has been pointed out many
times by now we could also come up with
even more examples of unjustified
shootings of white people not
high-profile because nobody cares but
they are happening okay in fact the only
example of explicit official systemic
state sanctioned or even state mandated
racism that I can think of and again if
you can think of a different one let me
know the only one I can think of right
now is affirmative action there you have
policies that explicitly discriminate
against certain groups they
discriminated against whites and also
especially white men and also Asians so
that is explicit systemic discrimination
there's an example now if you've got
something like that explicit state
mandated or sanctioned official systemic
discrimination written into a policy if
you have an example like that which
targets black Americans then let me know
what it is but I don't think you do have
an example or
can provide one well the main thing we
should take from this I think and
keeping in mind that polls can only be
trusted so much and also the group's
conducting it are clearly clearly biased
and also polls exist mostly to shape
public opinion rather than to gauge it
but even so all that in mind I don't
doubt the basic thrust here that an
increasing number of Americans think
America is racist and that number
whatever it is is probably over 50% I
buy that so we take from that first of
all the conservative case cannot win
cannot prevail in a culture that sees
itself as racist there is no there's no
such thing as a conservatism that also
buys into or even entertains this idea
of systemic racism and I'll tell you why
because conservatism is supposed to be
about conserving if it means anything it
means conserving defending maintaining
right what are we conserving well that's
a good question we should probably
figure that out at some point I would
say that we are conserving the nuclear
family we're conserving the sanctity of
life we're conserving the Constitution
we're conserving rationality we're
conserving objective morality we're
conserving Western civilization and now
we're even conserve fighting to conserve
basic scientific truths like the
difference between men and women which
is a very important fight as well the
problem is that the BLM set would tell
us have told us is currently shouting at
us and you can see it on their website
if you want they tell us that all of
those things to include concepts like
objectivity our channels of white
supremacy these are not just relics of
white supremacy these are current active
agents of it the Constitution nuclear
family all of that is
part of the systemic racism problem
which actually makes sense from their
point of view because of America is
inherently you know these are things
that are inherent to the to America to
the American identity and if America's
inherently racist then those things must
be as well so we cannot be successful in
concert conserving these things if the
left is successful in painting them as
racist which means that we cannot win as
conservatives if the America is racist
narrative is winning it's really one or
the other right now it's the other right
now they're they're the ones winning
which means we have our work cut out for
us and it also means that people ask me
all the time
how do we how do we come back from this
how do we reclaim the culture and all
that well there isn't any flip we can
switch there isn't any easy one two step
plan one two three you know follow the
steps type of type of thing step by step
plan for reclaiming the culture it isn't
as easy as that it also isn't as quick
as that and everyone's looking for the
quick fix immediate you know
gratification but that doesn't exist
with this this is a generational fight
this is what I keep saying it's
important for us to real it's a
generational fight the left has gotten
to us gotten us to this point by
infiltrating all of our you know major
American institutions the family
academia media corporate America and
that's how they've succeeded they've
done it over generations if we're going
to fight back it's going to be a
generational struggle that happens over
the over the long term you know we have
to sort of buckle up and be ready for
that for a fight that takes that long
and you know we have to be willing to
fight for our kids and our grandkids I
mean in our great craic is for people
and our families that will never meet we
have to be willing to look at it that
way because if you think you're fighting
you know if you're an adult in America
today
and you're fighting because for your own
sake because you don't want to live in a
country like this and you want to make
it better for you
well that's understandable I get that
but it's probably not gonna get much
better under your watch this is gonna
take longer than that to fix all right
let's go to five headlines today's five
headlines brought to you by the Benham
brothers learn how to own a business
without it owning you get a 50% discount
on the Benham brothers new course expert
ownership at Benham brothers dot-com /
walls number one 15 people were shot
while leaving a funeral in Chicago
yesterday here's the the local report on
that Chicago police telling us that
there were 14 gunshot victims in this
one incident that happened near 79th and
carpenter here in the auburn gresham
neighborhood tonight the shooting
actually happened outside of a funeral
home as a group was exiting that funeral
home a car drove by and started firing
at that group we are learning more about
the person being remembered it was a
service for Donnie wethersby he was 31
years old he was shot in the head a week
ago in Englewood again this happened
around six-30 tonight Chicago police
telling us it was that black car that
drove by the funeral home on 79th and
passed by that funeral home firing shots
into a crowd again 14 people were shot
but Chicago police say they found 60
shell casings on scene and that was
because the crowd actually started
firing back at the occupants in that car
Chicago police believe there may have
been four occupants in that car they say
that they do believe that they have one
person of interest in custody so just
another day in Chicago really I guess
that's what it's like in the city in
many cities Chicago especially but
Chicago's mayor Lori Lightfoot
she says that the citizens of her city
you know they're not really worried
about this about armed men gunning them
down in mass while they're walking down
the street they're not worried about
that what they're worried about are the
federal law enforcement officers that
Trump has sent in to Portland to take
control and really specifically to
defend the Federal Building there
that the angry mob has repeatedly tried
to burn down
we're told somehow this is a very
unreasonable step by the President to
try to prevent the mob from burning down
a federal building how dare you you
tyrant here's the tweet that Lori
Lightfoot sent out on the same night
that over a dozen people were sprayed
with bullets in her City she says under
no circumstances will I allow Donald
Trump's troops to come to Chicago and
terrorize our residents yes
terrorize our residents you really think
Lightfoot you incompetent ridiculous
hack you you think that's what your
residents are terrified by when they're
walking down the street you think
they're worried about a federal agent
coming coming and shooting them know
they're they're worried about what
happened to those people leaving the
funeral just come randomly shot this is
happening every day in your godforsaken
hellhole of a city that's what they're
terrified above and terrorized by number
two Ringo checking in Ayanna Presley
sent out this tweet says cancel rent
cancel mortgage cancel student debt
eighty-six thousand likes on that
doesn't take a lot of effort for the
left for leftist politicians and yeah I
like it too
I'm gonna add will make it 86,000 one
likes cuz I like it
only I prefer to add to it you know
let's like yeah cancel all those who
lets also cancel while we're at it
sadness loneliness tummy aches diabetes
death that's a big one
asteroids the law of cause and effect
you know it's to me really harsh is my
buzz I don't know about you gravity
cancelled so we can fly obviously and
you know why why not cancel war and
hunger while we're at it we might as
well I I can't believe no one's thought
of that by now like that that's quite an
oversight so cancel all the bad things
here's the point and this and this is
what I ana Presley is trying to say and
it's really quite brilliant what she's
saying
is canceled the bad things right now
listen to this listen to the next part
though okay cancel the bad things
alright step 1 step 2 have only good
things you see that really I mean just
incredible insight brilliant strategy
and this is why we need people like Iona
Presley in Congress with those kinds of
ideas number 3 Twitter's cracking down
on accounts and groups that are
dangerous which is good because you know
I can think of some dangerous groups
that are right now in the process of
ripping American cities to shreds you
know that that that would be maybe a
group you want to keep an eye on if your
Twitter or any other social media I mean
they do use these social media platforms
to organize and plan their felonious
activity so I could understand Twitter
cracking down on them but only of course
Twitter is not worried about those
groups instead they're targeting the
queuing on people here's the
announcement from Twitter and a long
thread they said we've been clear that
we will take strong enforcement action
on behavior that has put the potential
to lead to offline harm in line with
this approach this week we are taking
further action on so called Q anon
activity across the service we will
permanently suspended tweeting about
these topics that we know are engaged in
violations of our multi-account policy
coordinating abuse around individual
victims or are attempting to evade
previous suspensions something we've
seen more of in recent weeks and then it
goes on from there let me just say aside
from the obvious absurdity of going
after q and on when you've got an Tifa
using your platform to plan violent
activity aside from that if you're
trying to tamp down a conspiracy theory
especially conspiracy theory like q and
on this is not the way to do it this is
actually the opposite of how you do it I
could think of no better way of in the
minds of Q on people confirming
everything they think then by banning
them in mass
but first of all acknowledging them by
name so it's not even just a Twitter
saying conspiracy theorists it's kyun on
people that's what they're saying
acknowledged by name and say we are
targeting them for suspension in the
mind of the conspiracy theorists oh you
have just like if somebody was toying
with the q9 idea if they were on the
verge if they were on the gateway of
being a Qi on conspiracy theorists you
have just shoved them all the way over
the edge with this which if I want to be
conspiratorial myself I almost think
that's part of the point for Twitter and
other platforms they they want more
people on the right to buy into this Q
non idiocy because it makes us look so
stupid and it discredits us so they like
it and they're gonna do anything they
can to encourage you if I wanted to be
conspiratorial myself I would say that
maybe that's the pointer number four
okay let me read this to you this is
good always good to be alerted when some
new thing becomes racist you got to keep
up on this and there's a new thing
becoming racist every day so it's really
important what I actually do is I have a
an alert on my phone and I have it say
there's actually an app you can get and
any time a new thing becomes racist
it'll send you an alert and I can just
check oh this is racist now and I can
just you know I'll pick up my phone even
a couple mornings ago I picked up my
phone alert it says pancakes are racist
and I thought okay good because I was
gonna have pancakes for breakfast
they're racist now I'll go with waffles
all right so this is the latest thing
actually that app doesn't exist but
someone needs to make that app I throw
that idea out there actually I don't
throw it out I retracted cuz I might
want to do that myself don't do it you
can't legally I've just copyrighted it
all right this is how it works let's go
to okay where where was this which which
ridiculous publication Huffington Post
all right it says if a research group
today conducted a study on a single
gender or ethnic group critics would be
quick to point out that its findings
couldn't reasonably be applied to anyone
outside of that group or gender it seems
like basic logic right unfortunately
such is the case with the body mass
index a weight to height ratio used by
health care providers insurance company
and a scientific community there is
growing considers criticism for the use
of BNI BMI for example it doesn't take
body composition fat versus muscle into
account and a person's weight doesn't
correlate directly with their health
however there's not much mainstream
discussion about is racist roots and
then okay let me get to the part because
this is what matters
they're saying BMI is they start by
saying BMI is is not a great way of
actually measuring whether or not
someone is fat overweight or unhealthy I
actually agree with that I think it's
not good I think it's I think it is a
not a very effective tool in that way
but they also claim that it's racist so
let's go this is where they explain the
racist roots of the body mass index the
racist roots of the Viet body of the BMI
index go back a long way
created by Belgian mathematician Adolphe
II quit Alette
in 1832 as the Quetta let index the
scale was created I think we should
still call it the Quetta let in index
it's more fun to say the scale was
created using data from predominantly
European men to measure weights in
different populations although quite a
lot noted that it was a population level
tool and not meant to be used on
individuals physiologist and selkies
reintroduced the calculation into nine
1972 as the body mass index so that's it
those are the racist roots if you were
waiting for something else I was - that
that's it that's the whole that's why
it's racist is because it was used for
the data they originally used a lot of
European men
that makes it racist like it's some sort
of conspiracy against black people but
this is of course everything has to be
ready on the left now they can't just
merely criticize something it has to
also be racist which in this case is
completely pointless as it often is
because you can easily make the case if
you have a problem with the BMI index
you can easily make the case on a
scientific level we don't need to get
into it's somehow BMI is somehow a body
mass index is racist that's absurd
but don't you get into that there there
are many solid scientific reasons or a
lot of health experts
tell you that this is not a very
effective way of measuring whether or
not someone is really healthy or not and
I agree with that
maybe I'm you know and and maybe it's a
little bit selfish on my part because
you know I've looked at be a BMI indexes
and that sort of thing before and then
try to calculate where I am am i
overweight and oftentimes on those
things I'll tell me that I'm overweight
I don't feel like I'm over I don't think
I look overweight maybe I do it's
possible but I don't think that I am so
maybe there's a little bit of you know
maybe it's a little bit self-serving on
my part but I don't think it always
takes into account every everything that
needs to be taken into account all right
let's go to number five easy transition
here from Huffington Post to Teen Vogue
and you know what I was gonna read from
this but I've done too much reading
already and I can't even the title that
the headline is black power naps is
addressing systemic racism in sleep I
can't even stomach I I'm sorry I was
gonna read some of this I'm sure it's
pretty funny what they're claiming is
that well it's just right there there's
systemic racism in sleep now sleep
itself is systemically racist and they
actually call for the writer of this
article Britney McNamara at some point
me see if I at least find this part at
some point she talks about sleep
reparations that are needed we need to
have on top of regular reparations money
there also need to be sleep reparations
well I'm not sure exactly how that will
work you know I kind of feel like you
know if you're a black person you want
to take a nap go take a nap I don't
think you need specific reparations here
just like anybody else if you want to
take a nap you could probably carve out
some time in the day to do it
not much of a Napper myself but anyway
all right I'm not even gonna sorry I
can't I can't do it you can go to Teen
Vogue yourself and read that article if
you want to let's go to our daily
cancelation but before we do you know
there's there's so much going on in the
world right now and it's
to keep track of everything that's
happening and especially to get the news
without the left to spin but if you want
to do that that a readers pass is a
great way to do it you go to daily
wire.com and get a reader's pass this is
a membership tier it's already a bargain
at three dollars a month we've knocked
it down first mothers 99 cents so it's
basically as cheap as it could possibly
be you can get your access to our mobile
app and receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content as
well as you could join the community of
Daily wire members who are actively
commenting and discussing our content
with each other that's mobile and free
access to all of our daily wire news
exclusive op-eds and all of our podcasts
on our mobile app all for the low price
of one dollar go to daily wire comm
slash subscribe okay today for our daily
cancelation I'm afraid to tell you that
the Trump campaign is cancelled just
cancel the campaign as it is currently
being run is canceled they can start a
new campaign I'm not saying they have to
shut down the campaign completely oh but
they're gonna have to start a new one
because the the current one is cancelled
let me give you an example as to why
it's canceled and yes this is one tweet
fine but it's indicative of a larger
pattern
so yesterday Ivanka Trump who after
nearly four years in the administration
has at no point managed to demonstrate
why she deserves to have a job of the
administration aside from the fact that
she's daddy's favorite I guess but
Ivanka Trump tweeted this in and this is
in response to another tweet from a Dem
operative from back in the primaries and
that was something attacking Joe Joe
Biden for an op-ed that he wrote nearly
40 years ago where he laments a daycare
tax credit which is which he said was
being given to a lot of higher income
families who didn't need it and he
points out that it's it's not good for
our society to encourage people to place
their kids in daycare to go out of our
way to do that where they're gonna place
kids in daycare all day while their
children are being deprived of that you
know
access to their parents in that stable
family environment so that this piece
that he wrote I forget what that what
publication was in is a defense of the
nuclear family basically and an attack
against materialism and a lot of New Age
values it's maybe the say myst thing Joe
Biden has ever said or wrote but in the
primaries in 2020 if you're a Dem being
sane or formally saying at least is
embarrassing so they tried to attack him
for it it didn't work and obviously he
won the primaries now now Ivanka for
some reason randomly has resurrected
this line of attack which already failed
in the dem primaries and she's hoping to
bring it over to the general here's
Ivanka sweet she says I couldn't agree
more with senator Gillibrand and Senator
Schumer and spokeswoman and adviser
Meredith Joe Biden should explain to
America how a mom working leads to the
deterioration of the family biden in his
own words below and then she links to
the so the article now this represents
an attack on Biden by the Trump team
from the left it's an attack actually
from the far left
they're attacking him for once defending
the nuclear family and pointing out that
it's not a positive thing for society to
shift so completely to a scenario where
we're you know almost every kid in
America is in someone else's care during
the day rather than they're in the care
of their mother that's not a positive
societal development and there are going
to be some real ramifications that Joe
Biden was right about that
of course this is a far left attack from
Ivanka Trump a member of the Trump
administration and I know you might say
well well yes but for leftist voters
this could be effective and so that's
why she's bringing up no it wasn't even
effective in the Democrat primary if an
attack from the left didn't work in the
Democrat primary it's not going to work
in the general why would it all the
sudden work now and it didn't work
before
listen far leftist and regular leftist
if they exist anymore and moderate
leftist anyone who's even slightly
leftist none of them are voting for
Trump I hate to tell you they hate his
guts they want him gone they want him in
jail they hate him you they have never
hated anyone as much as they hate this
man I'm sure you've noticed that by now
you aren't you know you're not winning
them if you're Trump that's not going to
happen
attacking Biden from the left to appeal
to them is a fool's errand what you need
to do is mobilize the right and there
are many people on the right who are
completely demoralized right now and and
you have to earn as many votes from the
middle as you can and from the
politically disinterested as you can and
to everybody in those groups again the
only groups you can post possibly hope
to win this op-ed from Biden is
perfectly reasonable and correct and any
attack from the left against him will
not work with the groups that you need
to win and the only groups who can win
so I said this is addictive of something
that is the Trump steam utter failure to
come up with a coherent and consistent
ant Abidin message they have no idea how
to label this guy the messaging is all
over the place it's schizophrenic one
minute he's sleepy Joe the next minute
he's a radical leftist agent of social
destruction the next he's actually not
leftist enough see this this doesn't
work this isn't how you do it this is
terrible branding it's impotent its
incompetent I'm just some idiot with a
podcast and I know this Trump is
supposed to be some sort of branding
genius the people around him should be
professionals at the top of the game I
mean they've gotten to the highest level
how could they fail this utterly with
one of the most basic jobs in running a
campaign and that is that is is the job
of defining your opposition this is
supposed to be the thing that Trump is
best at now let me tell you
sleepy Joe is Alayne that's not taking
it's not working
nobody cares it's not resonating I know
if you're on the right you might like it
you might say no sleepy Joe is great
okay fine but he does it that doesn't it
doesn't matter if you like it forget
sleepy Joe okay nobody is gonna be
swayed on Election Day by the thought of
Joe Biden being sleepy I just don't
think that's not the kind of thing that
mobilizes people that get that it
excites real passion
I got a vote for Trump because the other
guy is sleepy no now crooked Hillary I
got a vote for Trump because the other
the other candidate is crook is corrupt
as it is a criminal yes okay that works
that will drive people to the polls no
one's going to show up to the polls and
then the other it's a someone a pollster
asome you know why are you voting the
way that you are well I'm just worried
about how sleepy Joe Biden is you know I
just don't want to sleep he got you in
there in fact if anything the idea of
having a sleepy few years after the
unrelenting chaos and madness we're
currently experiencing seems kind of
viscerally appealing i thing a lot of
people will hear that and say that
sounds great you kidding me I wouldn't
mind Evans a little bit of sleepiness
right now
um a similar problem with the attacks
related to Biden's son hunter the hunter
Biden stuff is red-meat for
conservatives on social media but nobody
else cares you know and and in general
trying to take down a politician by
attacking his family rarely if ever
works I can't even think of an example
when it ever has worked you know some of
the anti-bill stuff against Hillary was
effective but in the end she lost
because she's Hillary she lost on her
own accord and she was very very easy to
brand like I said Trump didn't have to
do very much everybody already thought
of Hillary as corrupt and that was the
message about her it was an effective
message it was consistent it was easy it
worked fine the other problem with the
hunter Biden stuff is that it gives
Biden a platform to talk about his
family and actually in talking about his
family that's when he's the most
compelling and relatable and heartfelt
those are those are actually great
moments for him when he starts talking
about his family there was that one
moment in the campaign when he was I
think was a pastor got up at a town hall
and asked him about you know overcoming
loss and he started talking about his
family this was this was a real
authentic heartfelt
actually powerful moment and I I'm
setting that okay as one of the most
cynical bastards and one of the most
anti Democrat bastard you ever meet even
I'm saying that seemed like an authentic
and powerful moment it's just to open
the door for that when you're the
opposition is politically suicidal what
else trying to make Biden into a fire
leftist that's no good either it's not
convincing nobody believes it nobody
sees Biden that way or will see him that
way just doesn't work he's too much of a
known entity at this point has been in
politics for seven hundred years
everybody sees him as a moderate and and
you know I don't think he really is a
moderate at least not anymore but that
doesn't matter what matters is how he's
seen and whether you as and the opponent
can plausibly make people see him
another way trying to make people see
Biden as a far left Marxist probably
isn't plausible at this point especially
when the Trump team has attacked Biden
from the left repeatedly and is still
doing it so what's left
the other option obviously is to
fine Biden as a senile old man which he
is who will be used by the far left you
know he might not be himself but he'll
be used by the far left to enact their
agenda which he will be so this has the
advantage of being a you know a branding
option and a line of attack that's
that's true that's real um but you know
it's also a little bit tricky to pull
off and it's risky it's probably the
best tact it's the reality but it
requires some wit and some prudence to
pull off successfully and wit and
prudence aren't exactly the hallmarks of
the Trump campaign I'm afraid to say an
example of the pitfalls here okay
the senile stuff remember that old
people vote they vote more than any
other demo you can't win without the old
people there's a reason why we still
have the Social Security system intact
the way it is even though it's a total
disaster it's not gonna be around for my
generation everybody knows it it's
bankrupting the country it's still
around because no you just you couldn't
possibly as a candidate actually propose
getting rid of it the old people won't
vote for you and if you're finished so
they're gonna get what they want if you
come off like you're attacking the
elderly or you're suggesting that older
folks are incompetent or that they have
no business leading and should just go
sit in the rocking chairs until death if
you do that you risk making Biden
sympathetic and and making older voters
angry at you and having them go to Biden
out of sympathy and spite sympathy to
him and spite to you that's a very real
risk here I don't hear enough people on
the right and in the Trump campaign you
know like acknowledging this you've got
to be careful with that I'm not saying
you don't you don't attack on this level
I think you do and again it's true
anyway and it really matters the fact
that we might have a guy who's going
senile in office and he's 79 years old
by the if he makes it through of his
first term which is that which is a big
if as it is he'll be it'll be 83 years
old the end of his first term this this
is a I've said before it's your chances
of
of over the age of 80 your chance of Gov
of developing dementia was like 20%
already and that's if you'll go into
your 80s without it so that you know
that is a a very real thing and I think
it could be effective but you have to be
smart and consistent in your approach
and the Trump camp has been neither of
those things at all as for being a
Trojan horse for the far left yes again
effective and true but if you're gonna
go the Trojan horse route once more
consistency is key let me show you how
inconsistent again the Trump camp has
been Laura Trump another Trump kid who
works for the campaign because Donald
Trump is basically trying to corner the
market on nepotism large crop was
interviewed by Breitbart yesterday and
let me just read
let me just read one thing she's talking
about okay hi you know what what was on
a Breitbart podcast and she was talking
about or their cerium Sirius XM radio
show she was talking about the need to
defer got it you know is it the Trump
campaign has to define Biden this is
what you have to do on a campaign and
here's what she says
defining our opponent and talking about
who Joe Biden is includes talking about
his cozy pass with Communist China
talking about and talking about the fact
that he supported the Clinton crime bill
which disproportionately incarcerated
young black men in this country now
here's the problem this this
article begins by saying that Laura
Trump was saying we have to define
former Vice President Joe Biden as in
league with the far left socialist
Marxist Democrats okay so she wants to
define him as in league with the far
left but also define him as someone who
supported a a crime bill that was a
little bit that was too harsh and that
was even racist you see the problem here
she's trying to paint him as far left
but then also tries to make him a racist
who locks up black men and is too harsh
on crime no no you choose Elaine you
can't do both you can't straddle both
lanes here moderate Americans and right
leading Americans aren't gonna be mad at
Joe for supporting a crime bill that's
the last thing they're gonna be mad
about right now if you're trying to beat
him by painting him as in league with
the far left then do that but don't
throw in little asides undermining your
own damned point
you idiots and no this is not a kind of
thing where you just throw it again you
know you might as well just say
everything and people can't like a grab
bag of attacks and whatever people like
they can grab out and you know whatever
whatever attack resonates with an
individual they can just go with that
doesn't work that way that's on how
branding works we look at look at
products that are you know good
commercials for products they're they
don't they don't don't know no one tries
a no competent marketing apartment tries
to sell a product by giving you 50
different things that you could think
about this product some of them
contradictory and then saying whatever
you know whatever whatever works for you
just think of the product that way no
you give like one thing here's your
message about this product buy it well
with Donald with Joe Biden if you're
Donald Trump it's it's anti marketing
it's here's the message about this
product don't buy it so that's why the
Trump campaign is canceled until they
figure out how to actually you know
campaign and I'm also
cancelling all of the sycophants and
yes-men including just Pete random
people on social media who are gonna you
know - just just will not tell Trump
he's wrong about anything and will just
cheer as as the campaign goes over a
cliff
yeah I'm canceling you guys - and all
right we'll leave it there on that note
very positive note to end on
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there